so first of all this film I don't even
know where to begin is so epic it's just
so big why I'm so sprawling so as a
director you wrote it so you put
yourself in this position to then have
to shoot these huge set pieces of these
long shots and the the one I love the
most is not gonna give too much away I'm
just gonna say there's a really long
fight scene long put together okay and
it reminded me of some of the stuff that
you did in Creed so talk to me about how
you were able to shoot it because if you
know this thing I'm talking about I mean
like literally it's just like and then
there's all tracking shots got a
fantastic crew stunt coordinators you
know Andy Gill and Jonathan a subió
great first ID visas Satriano
it's just you know great fight crew
Clayton barber while working on or creed
you know and it was focused great camera
crew always working with some attire for
Rachel Morrison she's incredible she ran
a she ran an incredible crew man
camera operator Scott Sakamoto operates
on everything you know so he's had a
fantastic crew and it was it was a you
know stuff like that you need a marriage
of of everybody you know you even have
to have your set built in a certain way
so you can move the camera through in
and we rehearsed it and practiced it and
figured our ways to accomplish visual
effects things you know my visual my
visual effects supervisor Jeff Bauman it
was incredibly never I was hungry you
know everybody wants to something
different something special for you know
for that scene if all the scenes but
that one was done was it was when I was
fun like this movie it's just different
than any Marvel movie because of the
messaging because like you put I don't
want to give too much but Chadwick and
Michael are giving me some like Malcolm
and you know what I mean like Malcolm
and Martin like vibes in this film
there's a lot of a lot to say so talk
about why you felt this film you had to
make sure that it was something past
what they've done before horrible I mean
for me it started with your started with
it
the source material no t'challa is a
politician he's a politician fire before
superhero short so we wanted to make
sure that that was highlighted you know
it was an opportunity for us to talk
about some things and and talk about you
know talk about things that you kind of
have to deal with know when you're
dealing with the idea of an African King
you know this African nation and for me
it was the question of man what does it
mean to be African you know it's a
personal question for me not that I've
been wrestling with all my life you know
ever since I found out that's what I was
you know um and in fact I think it's a
very interesting question but it's also
a universal question because you can ask
a person of Japanese to say hey what
does it mean to be Japanese and usually
they freeze you know yeah if you ask
them like that because because you gotta
gotta think think deeply about it and
that's a question that's that's that's
that's got infinite possibilities you
can research that forever I think our
story is specific you know in many ways
just the oldest story you know I mean
like like I stall this story like you
know they they they tell you you know
all human beings come from this place
you know and and so it's a story that
everybody should kind of have ownership
all very wise just to like work on is
you know um what a hell of a way was
this cast to kind of lead the charge and
asking that and asking that question and
to have you know different political
viewpoints on where this place should go
you know Lucy would kind of kind of
surrogate for the world I was there on
the set visit on a few guys remember but
I have been hyped for this movie since
then and then since being on set and I
think both of you have mentioned how the
vibe was just cool I mean I saw videos
of you playing the drums yes let's talk
about the vibe coming on set for this
movie because even back then I felt it
was electric it was a good vibe I was it
was some it was a good bunch of people
in front of and behind the camera and
you know you've been on enough sets to
know that it's it that's you try and
engender that all the time because you
know you your job whether it's on this
or anything else is the same you're
trying to tell this story as well as you
can and largely it's just full of people
trying their best and trying to succeed
in telling a story and this was no
exception and it was yeah there was a
lot of passion involved
as they're always easy but trying to
make a film you know it's it's it's not
easy to make a good film you know I've
sold a lot of people this as much as we
talk about it it takes is just as much
effort to make a bad to make it no one
sets out to make an a mediocre film
everyone wants to make The Godfather you
know and there's not many of them make
it that's all the thing is the right
Ryan does create a good vibe I mean he's
just through his own by dint of his own
personality he is a good good human
being and it just just comes off him and
and and what he wants to do the film and
the way he's trying to approach it and
have just everything about the way he
operates is just so it relaxes people
into into a very creative space it's
amazing yeah I want to definitely talk
to you guys about both of your
characters because I feel like they're
both different sides cuz it's not what
is we're told in the comics I'll put it
to you that way he's not the bumbling I
don't know what's going on no you
brought some swagger to every thought
about it well I mean obviously I was
very aware as I've said many times uh
the things I said to Ryan were I don't
want him to be a goofy white guy among a
lot of sexy called black things like we
know that we've seen it we've seen it
down a lot you know so uh why shouldn't
he be able to hold his own why shouldn't
he be a formidable cat and good at his
job you know it's much more interesting
makes the stakes higher if he can if he
can look to Charlie in the eye and you
know be you know be serious rather than
think you're gonna have your fangirls
already got one here you just play this
madman like let's talk about it the best
kind of bad man but a man is pretty
unhinged and inner hopefully and an
attractive really kind of kind of buff
what you know oh he's things to me
definitely I could bear like of the
screen when you're on your own I hold it
down well I
I enjoyed that messaging you know it was
such fun we had a blasting and all I
really enjoy and Ryan was just pushing
me to take it further and and that's
what I mean about kind of encouraging an
atmosphere not being afraid to try stuff
and and you don't always get that all
set sometimes it can be very pressurized
thing and you don't feel like you you
know I'm working with Martin who I adore
and we've worked together on you know
another staff and just so there was a
real sense of freedom and and so that
character was able to come alive because
of that really I can't say a lot and I'm
glad that I can't say a lot yes I want
everyone to experience it like I hash
write but girl you kicked butt in this
movie physically ready for this because
this is a way that I don't think a lot
of people have seen you I mean I haven't
seen myself do this kind of thing either
so we had about six weeks boot camp
before we started filming where we all
got together all those characters that
need to you know physically exert
themselves and we learned how to do all
the various things we needed to do we
would do warm-ups together and then
break off into our various um techniques
and so excuse me I have spent a lot of
time working with the ring blades and
learning how to use other weapons like
guns
Nakia Ryan described her to me as Street
you know she's worldly she's a
undercover spy so she uses any means
necessary to get the job done so I had
to learn how to fight like that as well
and then you know like the door and my
logic they have a way more traditional
and like graceful movement and they move
as a unit and everything it's so
beautiful to see everybody learning more
about their character and expressing
their character through that even the
way they they fight and that makes the
fight scenes I think so specific you
know and full of story rather than just
looking cool it's like it's telling us
so much about who these people are
yeah I love that and let's be honest
they do look really cool there's a
specific fight scene that you brought up
the spy aspect and I'll just leave it at
that we won't get into too detail but
this feels like a James Bond movie and
so let me be the first one to say you
were my favorite Bond
um also with this with that whole thing
is the look of the movie and the
costumes and I feel like Ruth did such
an amazing job creating these costumes
but I have to ask you were some of them
difficult to do all that but kicking in
because some of those are pretty
intricate cop they are extremely
intricate and you know I I because Nakia
is this you know she's undercover and
she's out in the world and stuff she's
dress is very utilitarian and so the
worst like the dorm logic costume has a
lot of components you can't wear that
costume on your own you really need like
a village to help you put it on and but
they were very smart about how they made
the costumes you know like they were
costumes made of metal and then they
were costumes made of faux metal that
look like so the when you had to do the
more you know the more intense stuff you
had softer fabrics to work with it was
kind of hard sometimes when it was hot
to be and all that in Atlanta I could
just imagine but I saw that coming to
America the point we please talk about
this you and deny basically and Daniel
yeah yeah it was our birthdays and I
said to them yo we have to have a party
and so they were like okay as long as
you plan it so I planned it and we came
up with this theme what Condon's in
zamunda and it was a perfect time to do
it because also we had Ruth we had Ruth
Carter and you know I went to her and
very quiet yes would you please and lend
me something for the party and she ended
up building my costume and a nice
costume and dressing Daniel and all of
us so it was just so much fun because
you know that film means so much to us
you know and so we were able to step
into it and then we're about to take
over so epic and I know you guys have
just y'all's career is just so great but
there has to be something different
about this film like I felt it watching
it I also got to do
set visit like every minute that I was
even watching you're talking about this
movie I felt like just had a different
flow like a you be on the set didn't you
feel it you know was just palpable just
what day were you there we did a set
visit I guess it was like late last or
2016 like we know we're still there and
we got to speak with everyone we didn't
get to speak with you although why we
were there I wasn't on that one cool
they just kept y'all under wraps from us
but anyway talk about what it was like
for you guys on set it was a beautiful
experience I love that you know I got to
work with you know my my dearest them
one of my dearest here and also to work
with you know well actors from across
the Diaspora yeah you know Africa from
London from here you know it just the
world was just so the large world was so
familiar as still it was such families
as if we were connected you know you
know that was really a special part of
making this movie I hope you could feel
that what she was saying that you could
feel the energy of like how that group
came together and stuff just by the way
you described I'm telling you I could
feel like idiots it was really exciting
to to be involved where everyone is so
committed together with a purpose and
one that's really a special one I think
yeah and you've worked with Ryan
produced his first film Fruitvale I mean
just his evolution from then to now
obviously you saw something special in
him then but working with him now on
this huge production I bet it was a
great book end or not booking probably
just a middle chapter yeah yeah yeah you
know no III I thought he was a portion
of real moral fiber and real
consciousness and really cared about
social fabric when I first met him he
was like you know working even with like
incarcerated individuals you know at the
time you know and and he had these ideas
and rubella was one of them and I said
okay we'll do that you know
and I could tell that I knew him right
away you could feel it from him I did it
the first meeting the first time we met
we said that we were gonna do that
together
and I think he still carries what he
carries with him that truth that I was
so impressed by and when you see him do
this film you can see his world view all
through the film it just touches
everything and it also touches he's a
true leader he inspired everybody till I
give all they could and they say these
messages which are I think important to
the world I loved what you said I heard
you say I never thought I would play a
queen that headdress with that that
crown you know with that with the gown
with the regal Ness of it the way it
makes you stand the pride that you feel
you know I think many of the characters
I have played that portrayed they are
our characters and real historic
individuals you know they are our queen
whether in culture or whether in civil
rights or whether just rearing families
whether staying strong and resilient in
the face of tremendous you know
injustice and death and insanity you
know carrying babies and rearing
children they they are our Queens but
this type also I thought well well that
won't happen but I that's how I see
ourselves that's I see black female you
know I see our men is King and our women
is Queens and be able to portray that on
you know the visual of that I I would I
would speak it and I guess there's
importance to to saying it out loud
because you know Here I am a part of
this magnificent moment that is black
panther what was it like for you
watching it last night it was my second
time seeing this cut of it so I was able
to enjoy it you know as high as far as a
performer
watching the work and watching what you
know you're sort of analyzing what was
kept in what was we had to cut him on
floor and why those incisions were made
so that's part of it to you letting go
of the film you thought you me to see to
watch the film that everybody else is
gonna see but it was amazing at the same
time and emotional you know feeling
other people respond to it here are
people sniffling and laughing and crying
and all that stuff is it's inexperience
yeah say Plus that every black celebrity
from like east to west coast they can
make it like oh I forgot this see was
Oprah at Obama y'all had like Isla and
Ava and Donald so who was the person
that came up to you afterwards that you
were shocked by what they were just like
man Snoop Jamie Foxx Jamie Foxx yeah it
was snowbirds the snoop was the most fun
you know they were they there naked name
is you know Jamie goes in when he's
feeling something you know you know
stoop was just having a great time I
feel like you've been at the after-party
and I saw like the director is all
walking out and I'm like when you see
James Gunn and Ty kontiki and like all
of these like a list directors being
like this is the craziest thing it does
mean testament to what you and Ryan do
um it's for me it's the fact that it
goes beyond you know the film community
community that you did you see people
outside of that embracing jeez you know
you know what I'm saying like like it's
become something else at that point in
time that's why I said no I I agree with
you and your partner in crime in this is
definitely I feel like it's Ryan and
then also Michael I guess what you guys
were able to do together talk about
working with the two of them and how
you were able to sort of I would just
feel like T'Challa just totally evolved
in this story so much because of what
you guys put up there like he's not just
what he was in this little glimpse we
saw mm-hmm
you know I think the the greatest thing
about this movie is that there's a the
conflict between the african-american
experience and the African experience
having the having a connection to your
ancestors and to be able to being able
to say my great great great great great
great great
that's what Wakanda is if they've never
been conquered like they can go back in
name and they'll know their names
whereas to be disconnected because of
colonialism because of slave trade and
not have that you know specificity and
in terms of who you are and how that
affects you emotionally to see that
clash and these two very similar black
men is something that we've never seen
on screen and it presents the
conversation in a way that we should and
must continue to to to have across the
Diaspora and I think also that house to
have that sort of in internal family
conversation in front of everyone and
have them sort of realize the the weight
of what all of that means on their from
their own place he's is a phenomenal
moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]